last night, Russian terrorists again
struck this attack aimed at our ports, at
our infrastructure, which is involved in
guaranteeing not ours, but common
global food security, and only
one month has passed since Russia's attempt to
destroy the Black Sea grain initiative.
Today was already the seventh, the seventh
massive Russian
Portrenil attack  port Southern port Odesa port
Chornomorsk Mykolayiv every
Russian attack on them is an attack on
world food prices it is an attack on
social and political stability in
Africa in Asia basic things that give
every society a normal life is
food food on the tables of families no other
terrorist in the world except  Russia has never
so openly and deliberately attacked the
security of so many nations at once
[music]
effect Ukrainian forevers and World Frost
On You Market
[music]